well we talked to screenwriter director
and screenwriting teacher John troubie
today and he said that the mark of a
true professional in this business is to
accept criticism and feedback about your
work without any defenses up which I
think would be very difficult for most
people so it sounds easy in theory but
probably much harder in practice so when
people have approached you about
anything not just us so this project but
about something else how does that for
you I mean if someone says you know what
I have to tell you I didn't get this
part of what you're trying to do I kind
of see where you're trying to go with it
maybe they're soft and it don't leave
read to you but still it's like it
stings a little bit because it's still
saying that your projects not perfect
how do you take that we're so used to as
actors just doing what the director says
and not arguing that there's an element
of that um an actor's face criticism all
the time you know constantly I think
that there's an artist you have to be
receptive to criticism in order to get
better and anise and as a writer to like
when we're writing I wrote the selling
but now we're writing together we want
harsh criticism of the script because
that's where you can fix problems you
know now if we show the movie and
someone says you know I didn't think it
was really that's like okay well thanks
for the feedback is not much I can do
about it now because I don't have the
money to go back and reshoot it so I'm
you know it's fine and if people feel
moved to come talk about it there's a
good chance we probably agree with them
because you know you're the most
critical of your own work yeah and you
know it's never what you want it to be
you know I heard Martin Scorsese said
every film has been on he wished he had
10 more days of shooting is marcus is e
so you know i don't think you'll ever be
satisfied with what you have so if
someone comes up and says something to
me about you know oh this beat here like
yeah yeah on the other
we got on the day have to take the the
source of the criticism we got a
scathing review that was so bad and the
first group first review first review
before we premiered at a film fest and
and I went and looked this was a blogger
and I went and looked through his other
stuff and he gave raising arizona a star
and a half no you know you give raising
arizona one star you gave us a star and
a half so we thought it rather than
raising her mama if so what's up if
someone doesn't like raising arizona I
don't want them to like our movie for
sure I feel like that was a compliment
right well on the flip side then how do
you deliver any criticism or feedback if
someone asks or even if they don't maybe
you feel it's your duty to tell them
that I really I think they're talented
and by telling this it might help it
depends if it can help or not like I
said that if their movie is done and if
there's you know if there's something
that could do editorially to fix it then
you know and they've asked for feedback
it's you know people you have to be
careful because sometimes people have
did ask for feedback really what they're
asking for is praised hmm and those
people are going to be receptive to you
no matter what you do so you can take
time and you can write a 10-page thing
but okay if you do this and this and
this and really trying to help them and
they'll just you know be angry at you
walk off so if someone ask for feedback
you might want to ask what type of
feedback do you want do you want you
know my general feeling do you want you
know a pat on the back do you want to
really dig deep like if people tell you
what they want and you can give it to
them as opposed to they make your blind
side that if you keep them a whole bunch
of notes on some we do a lot of readings
of our scripts with wonderful actors
that we're lucky enough to know and
those are places where we're really
looking for the worst thing that people
think and we may disagree we may think
know this team does belong here for this
reason and worthy artists so the were
the last word unless we start working
with super fancy producers so I think
that
asking for criticism and giving
criticism like Gabe said is is difficult
and you have to look at the source and
you have to look it at where they are in
the process and it's very delicate sure
and what if there were friends you think
it's easier to give a stranger criticism
than someone that you still want a
relationship with not if they've asked
for it okay unless it's really terrible
there's nothing they can do and then
it's awkward but I we haven't we have
very talented heads would never face
that before
you